is leaving our plan worked we saved our
own honeymoon and fun bonus we cheered
up halt yes okay it's time to celebrate
you know what that means this bee needs
a c in her a oh my God this babe needs a
coconut in her arms Oh I thought you
were saying this needs a oh my God yeah
that was my reaction all right I'll go
get us a couple of coconuts ah hey there
Captain I haven't seen you looking this
happy since they picked up the Drells in
Corfu for a fourth season yes well I've
reached the best part of every vacation
reviewing the charges well don't let me
interrupt have a safe flight I'll see
you back at the 99 uh no you won't I'll
never be going back there again what why
I'm confused you and Amy made me see
that there's more to life than the NYPD
so I'm
quitting
oh well what a satisfying result that we
all were hoping would
[Music]
occur